you won't remember this but way back in
2007 when collider was a nothing site on
the internet uh I did an interview with
you at Sundance for last Mimsy and you
know I just wanted to say back then
getting people to talk with us was more
of a challenge and I just want to say a
sincere thank you for talking to us back
then when the site was not much and I I
will always appreciate that all right
all right all right I want to start with
the sincere congratulations on this um
weird is fantastic I um honestly was so
much better than I expected
um what was it like for you reading the
script and seeing the way it was going
to satire like the biopic genre well
it's funny that you say it's better than
you expected because I felt the same way
like when they said oh they're doing a
Weird Al biopic
they're interested in you for Dr Demento
I read the script and I was like it's
like if this is like a comedy sketch
like a Saturday Night Live sketch and it
started as a funny or die sketch which I
heard like how is this gonna sustain for
90 minutes but the script was so tight
and they had worked on it so carefully
the tone was just right it takes itself
very very seriously and that's the kind
of Comedy I like where it's the most
absurd circumstances possible but it's
taken deathly seriously and there's not
any commenting on it's not like Hey
we're doing a goofy movie you know so
um as soon as I read it I wanted in I
thought it was just brilliant how it
kind of in an airplane like fashion uh
satirizes the musical biopic
without getting silly and goofball and
Broad so
was really excited to be a part of it
plus Weird Al is a hero of mine so one
of the things that I couldn't believe is
how short of a time frame you had to
actually make the movie
um I mean it was done I believe in like
18 days or something crazy crazy yeah
for a very low budget too yeah can you
sort of talk about that because when you
watch the movie it it looks so much
better and bigger than just this small
little film
well that's all on Erica Powell so the
director has done a ton of sketches and
the stuff for funny or die when you do
I've done a bunch of sketches for funny
or die and college humor and those kind
of places and you're given like
you know a very small budget here's
fifty thousand dollars and you've got
two days or a day and a half or one day
and you've got to try and make it look
incredible you know it's kind of a boot
camp for filmmakers you know in the same
way that Ron Howard started out in the
Roger Corman World a lot of you know the
great comedy directors start out in
those in doing those sketches and then
moving to TV and then when they get 18
whole days you know in a couple million
dollars they're like okay let me add it
we can do this and he knew how to move
the camera in ways and and cut and just
a lot of movement and life and music and
um it really made it feel like a a big
big movie I really enjoyed the pool
scene at demento's house uh with all the
cameos and guest stars can you talk a
little bit about filming that sequence
because you have so many moving parts
and uh it's just very funny yeah I mean
first of all we shot that and it was
really cold it was like 50 degrees and
we were supposed to be pretending like
it was 80. um and for La 50 is cold and
uh and then I had no idea who was
showing up that day and then all of a
sudden all there's like this Cavalcade
of stars was showing up at this house in
the San Fernando Valley and it was it
was interesting because they had told me
originally that they modeled Dr
demento's character after Burt Reynolds
character in Boogie Nights kind of this
impresario behind the scenes you know
Puppet Master bringing people together
so that was like a Boogie Nights Sam it
was like a scene from Boogie Nights only
it just happened to have
Pee-wee Herman
and uh Tiny Tim and divine and Gallagher
and Salvador Dali in it
um just so much fun such great
imagination and humor
um it was uh it was a hysterical uh part
of the movie one of the things that
people might not realize is the film won
the Midnight Madness award at the
Toronto Film Festival did you have any
idea like making this because you never
know when you make a movie how it's
really going to turn out did you have
any idea like how good it was going to
be you know um because winning the award
at Toronto is like it's a really big
deal listen I knew it was a small budget
I knew it was a short shoot but I also
knew there was a lot of great talent
involved Daniel Radcliffe gave it his
all I mean it Blood Sweat and Tears
shooting 14 15 hours a day learning
accordion
um
and uh and by the way he was grossly
overweight before we started shooting
and he did he worked out with some of
those Marvel trainers to get ripped to
play Weird Al you saw how ripped he was
it was like you could grate cheese off
those abs I actually heard he trained
with Chris Hemsworth for the role he did
yes he did Chris would would bench
Daniel right
um but then in exchange he would give
him some pointers so
um super fun
uh I asked this of a lot of people
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
me yeah you
um listen obviously most people know me
from the office and they always will and
that'll be on my Tombstone you know my
Epitaph will be the guy who played
Dwight but you know I did dozens and
dozens of rolls before I played Dwight
I've played dozens of roles after Dwight
I would say like my favorite role or one
I would love to be remembered for is the
movie Super by James Gunn
um I thought it was hit it was again
super low budget we shot that super
quick
um in Shreveport Scenic Shreveport
Louisiana but I think the combination of
humor Darkness tragedy insane
imagination my brain gets touched by the
Finger of God
um uh I think it's an extraordinary work
and I'm really proud to have been a part
of it yeah that's a very cool movie and
well before James wasn't playing in the
Marvel Universe
um my last thing for you uh you've
gotten to voice a little bit on solar
opposites which is a show I love
um can you sort of talk about getting to
be a part of that yeah um Mike the
showrunner of solar opposites he wrote A
Star Trek short that I starred in and
directed over in the Star Trek universe
over at Paramount plus and um where I
got to play hairy mud so we got to meet
each other and um he's he's incredible
he's a comic genius and it has an
unlimited imagination so loved being a
part of that universe as well yeah solar
offices is great for people that haven't
seen it
um on that note amount of time I'm just
gonna say man I really appreciate uh
your work I really thank you for your
work and I really will always uh thank
you for Sundance all those years ago
you got it man my pleasure pleasure
talking to you Stephen Weintraub of
collider thank you have a fantastic day
you too later